ja wir stecken mitten in der kroner
krise hier in europa und jetzt gibt es
deswegen auch mehr erkenntnisse weil wir
direkt mit dem virus zu tun haben und
zwar zu sehen sind toll symptomen und
wie man mit patienten oder patienten am
besten umgeht
das sind erfahrungen aus italien darüber
berichtet ihr und ja hier bin ich jetzt
in meinem studio tatsächlich das ist
mein blick wenn ich aufwache gleich
schalte ich das licht an
ja ich habe mich hier einquartiert und
berichte auch aus meiner quarantäne in
kriegs um science fiction die wirklich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und rot auf die glocke nur dann
verpasste nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen der ja zu einer sonderausgabe
von kriegs um die ich jetzt regelmäßig
zu corona mache und ja es verschlägt
einem eigentlich täglich den atem was es
an neuigkeiten gibt die neuesten
schätzung für großbritannien sind
möglicherweise 55.000 infizierte und
wenn man nach brasilien blickt wo der
präsident die infektion komplett
kleinredet die krankenhäuser überhaupt
nicht darauf vorbereitet sind
die verspätete reaktion in den usa aber
auch hier in europa wo ursula von der
leyen die kommissionspräsidentin heute
gesagt hat dass die politik zu spät
gehandelt hat ich kann nur sagen wenn
man klick so gesehen hätte dann hätte
man vielleicht etwas früher reagiert und
mir ist da ja immer wieder panikmache
vorgeworfen worden aber der tag an dem
jens spahn gesagt hat wir sind gut
vorbereitet auf das virus das war der
tag an dem man eigentlich hätte beginnen
müssen zu handeln aufhalten müssen den
exodus der atemmasken der
schutzausrüstung nach asien in dem man
nachsehen hätte können wie man den
mangel an
ärztinnen und ärzten an pflegekräften
und so weiter beheben kann an
intensivbetten aber man hat erst mal
einfach nur business as usual gemacht
und das war glaube ich ein
verhängnisvoller fehler der in vielen
anderen ländern jetzt in noch schlimmere
maße teilweise er wirklich gemacht wird
und aber mindestens genauso schlimm hier
in berlin hier unten sieht man grad die
kinder spielen auf dem hof weil die
spielplätze gesperrt sind aber sie sind
nicht überall gesperrt also das ist
schon alles sehr seltsam
ich habe jedenfalls meine konsequenzen
gezogen ja das hier ist das klicks um
studio und hier habe ich auch meinen
matratzenlager aufgeschlagen und blicke
jeden morgen jetzt auf diese grüne wand
ich habe mich in eine selbstisolation
quasi in der eigenen quarantäne begeben
und das ist ja eine forderung die auch
viele ärztinnen und ärzte stellen dass
menschen mit risiko und bei mir ist es
ja an asthma wo die werte jetzt im
moment sehr schlecht sind also halbe
lungenvolumen doppelte entzündungswerte
wo menschen dass menschen die eben
risikopatienten sind sich in quarantäne
begeben keinen kontakt mehr haben und
genau das habe ich gemacht also habe ich
ja im ersten video schon beschrieben
also hat eine geschlossen gerichtet und
ich kann wirklich de facto verhindern
kontakt mit anderen menschen zu haben
ja und eine hürde dabei ist ja so ein
bisschen wie ihr nämlich ich habe mich
architekt mit backmischung für brot und
ich glaube das ist die bessere lösung
als dosen brot und normales brot wird ja
einfach sehr schnell schlecht muss mal
so oft kaufen muss man oft in
lebensmittelhandel gefahr der ansteckung
und so weiter und macht das mit einer
brodbeck maschine
und ja das hat ja dann erst mal nicht so
gut geklappt
richter nein sie ist noch mal vom strom
ab sekunde und hatte denn jetzt hier
gemacht
nix
nix ja endlich erwähnt ist es ist super
einfach das zu bedienen
irgendwie ist das reagiert auch auf
nichts mehr
doch jetzt ist es fertig tatsächlich und
ich will mal sehen die große premiere
ob da wirklich ein verdächtiges boot
rausgekommen ist euch das an ein
richtiges leckeres brot und das mache
ich mir jetzt so dann bin ich da jetzt
mal ich habe so ein hefeextrakt viele
vitamine drin sehr gesund und gott sei
dank da muss ich erst mal ein riesen
dank aussprechen
ganz viele unterstützen mich hier also
die nachbarn freunde leute auf instagram
schreiben wir dir aus berlin kommen herr
christoph wenn du irgendwas brauchst du
eben heiliger praktikant oscar aller
mails angeboten und das natürlich super
das heißt ich kriege das ist hier
gelandet und eben wenn wir irgendwas
fehlt ja wird mir das gebracht und ich
glaube das ist wirklich wichtig eben
dass sich leute mit risiko faktoren in
selbst quarantäne begeben
alldieweil das dazu führt dass die
intensivstationen viel weniger
frequentiert werden und das kann die
situation wirklich deutlich entspannen
in deutschland so jetzt mal probieren
hmm ja
und wenn ich jetzt noch weiter in die
brutmaschine im griff habe
dann ist die blutversorgung schon mal
gesichert das gute am heutigen tag finde
ich es gibt nicht nur schlechte
nachrichten sondern es gibt auch immer
öfter bessere nachrichten zum beispiel
aus italien das liegt jetzt eine studie
vor aus der lombardei und das tröstliche
ist erstens kinder haben selten schwere
verläufe und zweitens menschen die
schwere verläufe haben sind dort
überwiegend durch die atmung wieder
gesund geworden
das heißt wenn die ressourcen da sind
ist auch einen gesund werden wieder
möglich selbst bei sehr sehr schweren
fällen
und es gibt noch eine gute erkenntnis
die hier gewonnen worden ist in europa
der virologe henrik strikt hat 119
patienten nur patienten untersucht und
er hat ein neues symptomen für das ist
ja schon indizien gab jetzt dingfest
gemacht tatsächlich ist es so dass zwei
drittel der kogit 19 infizierten 1 1 den
geschmacks- und geruchssinn für eine
weile verloren hat leider nicht am
anfang der infektion so dass es einen
hinweis wäre im vorfeld sondern erst im
verlauf aber so kann man während einer
erkrankung ganz klar feststellen ist es
mit 19 oder ist es eine normale grippe
influenza aber total krass und das ist
was schlimmes ist sind fake news ich
hatte das ja heute in dem anderen klicks
um videos schon ausführlich beschrieben
aber es gibt in deutschland einen
besonders krassen fall dr wolfgang
wodarg der es tatsächlich lungenarzt
aber mit 73 jahren in pension und der
zieht sich zahlen aus europa über die
sterberaten wo es ja gerade erst anfängt
mit den sterbenden und behauptet
saas kopf zwei das virus wäre genauso
schlimm wie eine normale grippe dabei
guckt aber eben nicht nach china wo man
die explosion der toten im vergleich zur
influenza sehr gut sehen kann und das
ist wirklich ich sag mal problematisch
dass selbst experten oder leute die
ahnung davon haben
fake news verbreiten wir sollten hier
wirklich nur fachleuten die auch ich sag
mal in gütesiegel haben wie sowieso das
robert-koch-institut dass hier wirklich
alle informationen wissenschaftlich
belegt zusammenträgt aufgrund dieser
habe ich mich in selbst quarantäne
selbst isolation begeben und da steht
alles was man machen muss und dort sind
die informationen einfach am
verlässlichsten eben auch die dass das
infektionsrisiko inzwischen in
deutschland hoch es also oder dr
christian drosten der leiter der
virologie an der berliner charité
das sind menschen die sich tagtäglich
damit beschäftigen und nicht irgendwo im
urlaub sitzen und ihre zeit totschlagen
müssen und dann wilde
verschwörungstheorien verbreiten also
auch das ganz wichtig selbst solche
leute kennen wir auch beim klimawandel
selbst solche leute ich weiß nicht warum
vielleicht um sich zu profilieren
verbreiten fake news also immer
aufpassen was die richtigen quellen sind
whatsapp nicht alles glauben was man da
weiter geleitet bekommt ja und so weiter
und so fort und aufpassen ich kann nur
alle bitten haltet abstand zu anderen
menschen bleibt in einen kleinen kreis
also weiter teure sozialkontakte nicht
zu sehr aus und dann kommen wir da durch
und in diesem sinne dann also bis dann
bleibt dran